ragazzi noi siamo all'episodio 8
episodio finale di mycroft harcourt
incredibile con pietro sia arrivato alla
fine però vabbè godetevi il video
stiamo correndo nel livello 90 cioè
running in the night
ora no quando senti no e poi board
escludo se il 91 91 e invece cosa hai
detto no
proprio lì 91 amico mio ma non è vero
allora questo ora che ci sono delle
nuvole la madonna ti si pensi quando mi
ascolta arriva arriva mamma mia
adesso sarà carino da fare riparati ecco
vorrei dicevo secondo me gli ultimi 10
non è difficile se non riusciremo gli
ultimi 10 secondi sono molto easy che
molto difficili gli altri in
confronteranno molto easy secondo me è
un porco demonio non so fare un salto
normale un salto nomiche dimmi amica e
c'è la mappa ci serve quel pezzo che noi
non abbiamo scuse che serve per qualcosa
per arrivare dove deve arrivare trova a
di saltare qua direttamente su bestie ok
e vabbè allora scappiamo siamo già
direttamente su questi vanno mai a ste
cose non funzionano ok ragazzi mi hanno
saltato sto pezzettino che bisogna usare
sti cosi che mai alla morte non funziona
però vabbè avremmo fatta in un tentativo
solo sicuramente riguarda non sappiamo
neanche cos'è quella roba quindi per
quanto ne so asciano slime c'è una scala
con lo zaino di marca l'ho già fatta
trovata occhio che cadi
ok arrivato dal pezzo delle nuvole ci
sei vieni vieni vieni mamma mia non ti
ho perso e lo fa lui definisce lo
termina 92 molto livelli tubo mannaie ce
n'è un'altra di porta così dopo è solo
questo poi c'è un altro
se continuiamo così siamo molto bravi
mamma mia mamma mia mamma mia la il bigo
perfetto 92 92 92 ed oltre che che si
illumina già la prego con la prego 92
però attenzione
bravo il 93 lo bravo lo bravo lo bravo
abramo abramo lincoln l'abramo lincoln
aspetta stasera ho sempre amata 2
protezione ma scusami ma ti fa entrare
in un altro settore ma ti rimane 92 del
casinò che voglio vedere arrivare fino a
qualunque ci fanno sognare conservati
sono fatti benissimo il problema è
sempre quello se sbaglia una virgola
parte da 40 anni parti e che deve
ripartire a capo lo salta tra qua si no
sì 93 ragazzi mamma mia che casino è
difficilissimo mancano otto livelli
voglio finirla sta roba voglio clicco
fammela finire per cortesia va col a
sepang la lega non mangia mai sono già
qui sopra sono fortissimo sono
fortissimo sono troppo forte e sta
andando avanti vieni bravo un attimo
bravissimo si portano avanti bravo bravo
bravo ma sono forte guarda mi sto
vincendo sta facendo tutto giusto non è
vero sono portati o bravo vieni qua
bravo perfetto ora qua
occhio perché un casino fai così qua
invece sembra facile però attenzione
perché tra un coupé l'altro io
continuerò da sola allora ok ok
sì
e poi ci sono cose belle e 94 amico
amico lo giochiamo se amico si guarda
aspetta devi me non lo so cosa se mi hai
fatto saltare un pizzo di mappano ok no
no perché pensavo di non arrivarci può
invece mai dietro da di bot da potrà
così perché non so dove stiamo andando
in questo momento però ma neanch'io prof
ma dai maya esatto stiamo andando a caso
vai vai vai e non è facile st parte se
per essere al 94 da siamo alla fine dio
mio dio mio ok ma devi fare il piano
ecco qua non salutare la gente qua come
degente opec sonore giocata da pécs live
non è quello di visitare il suo
matrimonio
quello che non volevo fare io però dai
ce l'ho fatta vedere di meno ridere di
me mentre salto io sono forte che non
sono sicuri di dove devi andare anno sul
tetto tipo ok ero potevi farlo
mamma mia mano 26 sacrificato to
perfetto io non l'avrei mai fatto
teorico la scala influenze 95 broncos in
scioltezza e lo fanno non sentono non è
ancora non dire gatto se non ce l'hai ce
l'hai nel parco vice di qua come è
giusto 95 visto cinque livelli alla fine
ragazzi come si salta qua ce l'ha fatta
maya guarda con occhio poco occhio
perfetto nel progetto unione icon avevo
visto proprio visto st parte le figaro
mi sembra aiuto dai sono fortissimi ma
guarda che formule che secondo me qua
ogni scusa è buona per farci vuoi farci
cadere qua
anche secondo me sai prova c'è una scala
come se dovessi riuscire a risalire di
qua sei sicuro può mai melanoma questo
web o no l'ora di me aspetto con una
volta sono qua
ok ok ma riguardo sei ore a detta di non
scendere qua ok in avanti in avanti ora
in avanti ma io quelle linee sono
problemi hanno piano piano però mamma
mia mamma mia
e adesso il confetto mamma mia ma questa
è andato amico che su salice mamma mi
bastava però ripartire minchia per per
un attimo detto pensavo di dovermi di
fare tutto livello di prima pagina de la
destra quanto ho capito non fare madonna
no no ma oramai c'è oramai basta troppo
di tregua sui pugni 3 quasi pugni
possiamo si scuote anche che l'organismo
è la fine poi non puoi non puoi quindi
nota perche sembrassi di questo tipo ti
incazzi resti a morgan sono caduto qui
se non credi ti venivo da riempirti di
schiavi ok ok
oddio ho fatto un salto
involontariamente che era giusto
madonna che sta facendo il giro questa
particolarmente che io vorrei vedere
appena riam al 99 come si prospetta
l'entrata al trono misto al centro dire
bene ma sono okay chiaro andare qua è
fighissimo alto livello ovunque ecco
perché è concentrato in poco mamma mia
se manca mi ripeto in uno visto alla
fine stiamo andando avanti a caso come
me anch'io
ok no no ragazzi non ci sono già i sky
si parla ora che il figo che dico sì
tutta l'acqua che manca alla fine penso
poco perché qua allora vai tra il
bravissimo madonna del vento
l'ultimo gradino
mamma mia che cacchio 97 tre livelli
alla fine amica sono 100 me magari non
sono 100 pro capite di good ormai sono
arrivare ma oramai ma è come niente vai
più male
morì per nulla pensa se mettono una roba
che caduto all'indietro di tantissimo e
giusto sera di qua ok lavoro gode nostra
mamma mia
resta fermo che provano che il libro
sparse torgiano pare fosse veramente
difficile mamma mia non è fatto sì che k
diary hunt 8 ti prego finire a uno alla
volta fermo sai così farò un'altra
immagine jolo cava ca o gravissimo devi
giampà dall'altro sono forte
bravissimo ha bisogno di chiedermi come
sapevo farlo sceglie il vero 90 98 98 va
giù che mi sono cagato ciao
ma accanto livelli mancato livelli corri
corri con un puledro impazzito fuori ma
questo cosa vuol dire questo non lo so
sto correndo sto correndo babbo di
arrivare a 100 amico mio non so se è
chiaro i gunners
ok ok ok ok ok
mamma mia che tutto d'un fiato sto giro
nota essere arriverà la parte difficile
via moretti è giusto è giusto si era
quello che pensavo che lei no ok
supermario di supermario è giù 99 99 99
anche un livello a destra la pirla ma lo
vedi ecco sono voluto andare saranno
sono riuscito c'è un
c'è un punto che è veramente difficile
soldi e perché questi non erano proprio
facili da allora qua è difficilissimo
perfetto perché sei ma dove sei tu ora
sopra come hai fatto a scoprirlo è un
inventa water park
hai capito
madonna non è difficilissimo però è
veramente difficile questo perfetto
l'ultima ma grandissimi amori voglio più
vedere questo livello
orribile è stata la cosa più brutta che
ho fatto da quando abbiamo stato parco
rto giuro su dio
la cosa più brutta amico mio
e siamo al centesimo schifosissimo
livello che vale 100 100 lire è questo è
l'ultimo e la torre finale amico si
parte ragazzi il livello finale speriamo
di trovare divertimento ma soprattutto
tanta tanta rabbia
se poi salta qua si all'acqua che ebbe
mamma mia ragazzi siamo all'ultimo sono
sto male wow
ok fa già qui a guardo che sia perfetto
ok l'acqua direttamente sì ma tonino
piani my friends difficilissimo profilo
per adesso ok non l'ho fatto a di qua
noi molto bene questo movimento ci dove
23 che ai legni perfetto no no kcal h
questa roba e legna normale elena de
corteggiata
che cosa significa sente non attivo
pensato che dovessimo buttarci giù
perché l'acqua non ci riportava solo
meno male che mi stavo sbagliando esatto
perfetto che vorrei vedere mamma mia
guarda non veline anche non vedi quanto
manca alla fine capito perché la misura
estro ita perfetto va di cava ricordi
cosa dico io o paura insieme ma ciò deve
fare
e poi c'è un punto in cui cadi e no devi
fare tutto il gioco nome nuovo per
quello sarebbe veramente una tipa
getting over
io non ho visto morto per un attimo
perché lì in acqua mamma mia se caschi
di qua mancano dei kart
mamma mia quanta roba porca vacca loro
mamma mi era presente signori
percorrendo tutti i biomi cos'altro
sennò è difficilissimo il ghiaccio
starci fermo ok non è loro muoviti mare
non è mai the parts of the board ci sono
la sua amico amico aspetto che ci
aspetta aspetta aspetta
mio dio ci siamo verso la fine
esatto è quello che sto vedendo vuole
vedere la persona se si vede qualcosa o
mio dio ci siamo amico
mamma mia che figata schiaccia lo
schiacciano io ho l'onore io vi siano
insieme 30 6 ore e 44 minuti e 33
singola ventola vedi atene comparso la
meta che dopo di settimane di giocare un
po a 7 ore di gameplay
mamma mia ragazzi a mike arco pyramid
parkour si interroga guarda che il parco
non è ancora finito lo ricordano ma
basta come fattoria con già allora mai e
intanto mediamente un altro è sappiamo
fare gol
ecco il punto più alto di tutto l'ente
parco vediamo un attimo livelli
bellissimo queste stato veramente la
miglior ma povertà
[Musica]
no